all right so it looks like we're live
now uh welcome to the fourth dr sadler
philosophy forum i'm doing something a
bit new this time i've actually
invited on a friend and colleague caleb
bernaccio
who is going to be doing a lot of the
discussion and and answering a lot of
the questions in this you could say i'm
outsourcing some of my work
i can i can rely on on caleb to uh to
handle a lot of the things that i might
not be as well versed on so i'm gonna
run through sort of a brief bio of caleb
who i've known for for quite a while
through the international society for
mcintyre and inquiry
and then i'll um give a you know sort of
brief rundown of what we're going to do
here
and then we'll we'll jump right in
so
caleb is working on an mba at louisiana
state university
he's got a background in both philosophy
and theology he was a seminarian with
jesuits and the diocese of baton rouge
and he's also like me although he's he's
done an awful lot more with this a
fellow veteran of the us army
and he's been a member of of
the international society for mcintyre
and inquiry pretty much from the start i
think 2007 is when it got rolling
that's how we met his interest is in the
relationship between tomism so the
philosophy of st thomas and
aristotelianism
and how those things can be applied in
organizational studies management theory
and economics so some very contemporary
concerns
and what we're going to talk about today
are two
rival moral theories the aristotelian
way of looking at things and the
conscience way of looking at things
and we're focusing in particular on on
moral theory so we're looking at
questions of of uh
what one ought to do and how we can
figure out what we ought to do
so we're looking with these two guys at
the relationship between rationality and
happiness and
the good life or or or the moral life
some of the questions that we already
have
seem to be a little bit more about about
uh what we would call speculative or
theoretical philosophy and less about uh
moral philosophy but we might feel them
um so caleb is gonna talk for a bit
about about aristotle and content i'm
i'll ask questions from time to time or
jump in
uh if uh if needed and then we're going
to sort of swap off a little bit and
talk about uh two other people to other
moral theorists who who are very
interested in i'm going to talk a bit
about wd ross
and then caleb will talk more about
aleister mcintyre
and i think what we'll do is we'll we'll
take a brief you know q and a session
after talking about aristotle and kant
and contrasting them and then we'll go
back to the presentation and then we'll
go right back into the uh the questions
so
caleb uh
this is
your your show at this point uh do you
want to talk about aristotle first or do
you want to talk about kant first
uh yeah i plan on talking about same
order aristotle and then khan
so aristotle on on rationality and
happiness what's the connection there
um well first off i just want to thank
you for having me on i think it's a
really great idea and uh
you know i think it's uh
very great to be uh exploring the role
of uh
of technology and how it can sort of
contribute to the possibility for
you know philosophical inquiry something
that's not often thought about i don't
think
but um
so so you know starting off um
i mean
the the first place you would look
thinking about you know
uh questions of ethics and
happiness with aristotle of course the
nicomachean athletics
um and right in the first the the first
book um
there's uh you know
aristotle essentially
um notes that uh
every art or science has an end
so you know you kind of approach this
and you're trying to
kind of figure out okay where is he
going with this you know and uh
essentially he he wants to uh make the
claim that
um
you know every art of science has an end
in it they're you know these are sort of
hierarchically ordered
uh i believe the example he uses are uh
something like um
uh bridle making and then horsemanship
and then military art
and political art and you can kind of
get a sense where
um these goals
you know
um are each kind of subordinate to the
to for their higher goal
um
and then
he follows that up um
and he says that
he says that uh you know if there's some
end for the sake of which we do
everything else then that's the ultimate
end
and uh you know there's one point here
that might be worth thinking of um
because it doesn't quite follow that
every action has an end that there's
that there's an end of every action
people you know often kind of say well
aristotle's committed this fallacy of
composition or um
but um there's actually a parallel in
the uh
udamian ethics which i think is very
helpful um
aristotle says that you know um
we must first then we must enjoin on
everyone that has the power to live
according to choice to set up some
object of the good life to aim at
with reference to which
uh he will then do all of his actions
and uh
he says since not to make one's life
organized with a view to some end is a
mark of much folly
so um i i think the way to think about
happiness with aristotle is that
it would be a mistake to think of him
sort of as trying to
approach this
in a foundational a sense is trying to
sort of uh you know prove from these
sort of uh
indubitable premises
to this you know conclusion that we had
this this sort of end i mean that's just
not his his mode of arguing i think that
um
you know again he's using uh dialectical
arguments he's kind of taken from a
common understanding
and um he's basically saying that you
know um
it's really not plausible
to think of uh
to think of life as sort of uh or a
candidate for a good life as being one
where there's no sort of uh sort of goal
or overarching purpose
and um
you know i i think contemporary liberals
might sort of object to that but i i
think aristotle he noted three uh forms
of life that were sort of most prominent
uh the life devoted the pleasure the
political life and the life of
contemplation and i think he might uh
you know point to to many uh
contemporary liberal views as being
basically like you know a life where
pleasure is kind of put in the in the
forefront so without getting too far
from that the point is that
for you know
aristotle thinks that um
that happiness um
is
kind of the structural goal
of life that um
that the issue is more a matter of uh
determining what happiness is
so you know a lot of people agree okay
well yeah you know we want to live a
good life or a happy life
but um the disagreement comes into what
that kind of what constitutes that
and um
so
you know uh he he
he just won't allow um you know for
various reasons right pleasure honor
wealth things like that he he points to
shortcomings and all these um
all these possible uh you know
structural goals of life um you know
wealth for instance you know i mean he
points to its instrumental nature
wealth is good for some purpose but in
itself you know uh
doesn't it's not useful for anything um
but um
so you know i mean
conditions you know that that follow
that
he kind of points to or the idea of uh
you know happiness is being final
self-sufficient
the final self-sufficient end of action
so again you know um for aristotle
uh happiness is this kind of structural
goal
uh as a structural it's a goal that
structures
a person's entire life
um and so the mat the question for
aristotle is figuring out what's an
adequate
uh notion of that sort of goal
um
ultimately um
he uh he pushed forward
what's commonly known as the the
function argument
in uh the beginning of the epic in one
seven um
but basically
he's he's sort of looking at uh he
mentions a flute player or you know
other sort of uh
crafts or things that there's if there's
a if there's a function here
um
we can think of what uh
what what the what what doing that
activity well is so for instance for
flip player
um you know it's pretty clear to be able
to say what a good flute player is
um
and so when he's looking at human beings
you know he's gonna uh
he's gonna say well you know we we
couldn't think of the function of human
beings as being
uh what we have in common today with
plants you know mere living or or
sensible life you have a sensitive soul
um
uh so he's trying to look at what proper
human beings and ultimately
he concludes that this is rational
activity
so um
essentially his conclusion is that the
function of a good man is is good in
noble
rational activity or you could say
virtuous activity
uh according to the
best or
most complete set of virtues
so um
so what do you what do you think that
means for
those of us that aren't yet you know
fully virtuous
um
how does how does reason come in there
we're not we're not fully rational in
the sense of you know having the virtues
telling us what to do taking the
reasonable path just sort of uh you know
without having to do an awful lot of
pushing ourselves to do that
uh and yet at the same time we can
recognize that's that's a better way for
me to be than than how i currently am
you know i should be making some
advances towards that
how do you see that fitting in there
um i think it's really one of the great
things about aristotle because i think
he has a very realistic uh
you know moral psychology so um
yeah i mean
the idea is that it's through
through habituation through through
practice through doing the things that
virtue requires
that
your your passions or your you know your
various drives are ordered towards the
good the natural goods you know um
so
you know uh he places a high emphasis on
the role of education and even sort of
political life in a sense and understood
and you know in his terms but um
so the virtues
the virtues i mean it's interesting
right that the greek word uh for for
that
is translated as virtue is also
translated as excellent
so you know i mean when he's thinking of
you know virtuous activity he's talking
about excellent activity and so you can
kind of draw a connection between um
you know uh
what it means to be you know to to to
act well and then you know by
understanding virtue in terms of
habituation
uh can really kind of spell that out
well you know it's through sort of a
real practical kind of experience that
you can kind of develop
those habits that enable you to be
virtuous
yeah um that that that's a good
sort of way to frame all of that
how do how do you think you know he
talks about um
the need to to figure out the right
means to the ends that we want so that
the general end is happiness but we we
don't frame that usually to ourselves in
terms of virtuous activity accompanied
by sufficient wealth with you know
family and friends um
and i don't think he expects us to be
doing it that way you know to be
carrying out this very explicit process
of reasoning
um how do we do this day-to-day i mean
you know one of the things you're really
interested in is is business ethics how
would this play out in an organization
for example
yeah it's interesting to say that
because i mean the one point that i that
i um
i really think
um that is necessary to think of and
aristotle actually even mentioned this
after introducing this idea of uh of
happiness after spelling out in terms of
function
um is that you know he mentioned that
this is just a sketch and uh in a sense
it's a very formal notion here
and um
so you know i mean there's several ways
to think about how this is actually made
concrete but i really think that to
understand in aristotle's terms and then
uh kind of segue into how kind of in a
business context um
so
uh i mean in a real sense happiness is
both an ethical concept but also a
political con
that's for aristotle so right in that
you know he in the beginning of politics
he talks about how
you know communities or political
communities are ordered towards
essentially the highest good
in the
rhetoric uh he goes through explaining
happiness
um as a premise that you would use in
rhetorical arguments so
i think that the first point would be
um for aristotle at least um
understanding concretely what it means
to be happy or virtuous in these
contexts in certain any given context
let's say
um
really depends on your
your uh social context he
the laws and the and the
uh deliberative context that that your
you know
want to call political framework allows
you now we live in a very different
context so it can be kind of difficult
to think about that
um
but then on the other hand i mean
through participating in these
activities uh he thinks we'll develop
the
the virtue of phrenesis or prudence or
practical wisdom
um which in a sense is allowing you to
kind of understand where the principle
is where the mean lies
in that matter you know that you're
whatever circumstance you're dealing
with basically being able to kind of
understand the situation
uh it's not something that aristotle
thinks you could articulate you know
sort of
from the armchair here you know i mean
that's something for the actual
participant
but that actually brings up an important
point so i mean practical reasoning for
aristotle if it's going to work right is
different than theoretical reasoning
um it has it has a different structure
and a different logic and it's a little
bit more loosey-goosey in a way
so so for nasa's it becomes incredibly
important
and i think that often gets overlooked
when people are are you know
interpreting
um what aristotle would be in in
relation to other thinkers where where
they
the the connection between
reasoning in a theoretical
context and reasoning in a practical
context is uh much closer
um
so can you tell can you talk a little
bit more about phronesis and how it fits
into practical reasoning
yeah so kinesis is you know um
sort of the unifying virtue at least at
least for aristotle um in a sense i mean
um
so there's this weird you know sort of
overlap that
weird when you try to kind of think of
them as separate virtues because
um on the one hand no virtue
is possible without pronisa
and uh it's pretty clear that francis is
what kind of allows you to kind of
kind of grasp the principle or the or
the sort of uh
again the mean kind of um you know what
whether it comes in to matters of
temperance or courage so for instance if
we take something like courage
uh you know it's going to be phenesis
it's going to tell you okay here's a
situation where i need to put my life on
the line
for some good to go to my community
um
and be able to allow you to distinguish
between another possibly very similar
situation where
uh
it's a matter of rashness that's kind of
leading you to kind of uh you know again
risk your life you know and so
um you know
but on the other hand
bernice's is not possible without all
these moral virtues
so
if you're a person who you know lacks
temperance or lacks courage um it's very
likely that when you come to that
situation where you need courage
because of the overwhelming fear you're
gonna say well no this isn't really this
isn't one of those cases where i need to
risk my life you know you're going to
reason badly
yeah because you lack moral verb
this is this is one of those things that
i've always found um
puzzling with when like
just reading the text and just straight
you know without trying to interpret it
at all
because it seems like
i know i don't have all the virtues
and
most of the people that i know certainly
don't either and yet i want to say that
they've got some some measure of uh
phronesis some measure practical wisdom
because they seem to be doing okay in
this context with with this sort of you
know thing that's governed by this this
virtue and not so good with with this
one so somebody might be
um
they might be generous but not temperate
you know um they might be courageous but
also not very have a very good control
over their anger um
and so i i i the only way i can make
sense of this and maybe maybe you have a
better solution to this is to say
when we look at that passage about the
interconnection between frenesis and the
other virtues we have to look at these
as like matters of degree that
unless you have some degree of of
phronesis you're not going to be doing
okay with these other virtues because
you're going to go at things in a very
schematic way or or be tempted like you
said to you know cut corners and say
yeah i think this situation isn't one
that calls for courage you know when
really it does
um
so you have to have some measure of it
but it's something that we could we
could grow and grow and grow you know
otherwise how do we get it in the first
place that's
that's the big puzzle
yeah
go ahead i think you're right i mean i
think that the whole thing would fall if
you interpret it too rigorously
um
in a sense the whole thing would sort of
fall apart and and um
you know um
if if anyone was truly ever virtuous you
know we most likely never met him you
know
and uh you know unless you can
understand in a matter of degree
uh it doesn't become it's not very
practical it doesn't seem like it
actually has application in any
uh experience and um i mean it
definitely is it definitely is an issue
i i think that um
um
you know uh
say for instance like with the stoics
right and there's a sense in some of the
stoic writers that um
you know
uh the wise man is sort of
unapproachable uh
you know uh
being you know and then um
you know uh i think aristotle it's a
little bit softer in aristotle i mean
there's a sense i mean he does kind of
say that you need all these virtues
together
um but i i think there's also sort of
room to kind of
uh
you know use your your solution here
that this it's possible in a matter of
degree
um
so let's let's move on to [ __ ] we can
come back to aristotle unless there's
any other things you really want to put
on the table at this point
uh the only thing you know i might
mention with um about you know kind of
mentioned about about business or about
um
i think uh
you know i think aristotle is
really in one sense the most plausible
candidate for actually speaking to
business issues in another sense the
most difficult because
on the one hand i think unlike many
contemporary or say modern ethical
theories um
where there's sharp separation between
sort of political questions and
questions of ethics aristotle recognizes
that your
ethical reasoning and ethical um
just sort of ethical questions aren't
independent of you know your social
structure
um
and so whereas you know it can be
somewhat easier to sort of develop a
kantian you know uh account of business
ethics where you talk about uh you know
these things are you know against the
category of imperative or when you start
to to think about aristotle you really
have to start to think about
not so much ethical questions but those
questions of you know what is what's the
what's the aim of the organization
what's going on here what's the purpose
um
you know so um just keeping that in mind
because when we get to mcintyre i kind
of want to talk a little bit more about
that but um
you know so again moving on to khan um
let's see
uh you know
i think to keep in mind when you
approach context this very different uh
context uh
in terms of the views of of knowledge
and epistemology and you know so
prominent in in in that time right those
are the those are the driving questions
you know uh
you know how do we know um i mean khan
himself said he's inspired by hume you
know that's what you're walking from his
uh dogmatic slumber to start to you know
so um constantly when kant is talking
about
uh you know
ethics and he's trying to develop you
know
you know kind of fundamental moral
principle or source of moral value
uh he has in mind um
sort of a criteria
you know about um what it means to be
a law which he thinks is
you know it's gonna be the foundation or
has to be the foundation of moral
uh of morality but it but just to keep
you know just keep him i mean
he constantly talks about the necessity
um
or that that something possesses in
order to be universal uh
or
i think it had a universality necessary
to be a moral principle so you know um
he has in mind these kind of
epistemological
uh you know criteria that you know he's
kind of bringing with him in a way that
you won't find an airstyle i mean
obviously just some of these questions
but aristotle is not constantly asking
you know okay well you know is this
sufficiently universal to be you know a
moral principle
aristotle's really interested in you
know is this a good goal um
so uh you know the first thing that kant
looks at is when he talks about
uh the good will the goodwill is the
only thing i'm i'm thinking of
especially the groundwork for the uh
metaphysics immoral
um but the goodwill you know he says is
basically um the only thing that is
good in itself you know or sort of
qualifiedly good yeah
you know so um
um
so you know that that's kind of becomes
an important point again um i think
there's sort of stoic sources for this
and again you see this kind of contrast
with aristotle who's he's not really
looking at things in this way you know i
mean this question comes up in some ways
but um
you know the other thing to keep in mind
is that is the role of happiness
in uh in context just so radically
different even an understanding of
happiness so you know he argues that
happiness is not the aim of reason yeah
he has some some interesting ideas i
mean i i always try to find it tough to
wrap my head around calm because on the
one hand he wants to claim that we
really can't know a lot of things but
then on the other hand he is going on
about how he knows you know exactly what
nature would have sort of given us you
know but essentially he's arguing that
um you know had nature wanted us to be
happy we had been like other animals we
wouldn't have had reason
um
but what you what you really uncover
behind you know this claim is
um
what his conception of happiness is he
says explicitly that happiness is
basically the some satisfaction of
inclination
yeah
so so again some very different from
aristotle
and in a sense i mean that would be one
view of happiness the view that
aristotle the one of you that aristotle
criticizes the idea that pleasure is is
kind of the uh you know the overarching
goal of life you know and so you know
all these little things that might make
you happy or give you pleasure well
those are unified by this idea that you
sort of seek pleasure um
but khan also says interestingly right
it says these judgments regarding uh you
know the fact that happiness isn't isn't
the goal of
reason he says are covertly found in the
idea of another and far worthier purpose
to their existence to which
and not to happiness reason is quite
properly destined so basically that
there's the claim is that there's
another purpose
that reason is ordered to
um
you know ultimately um
the other end right what what is his
purpose
um
is
life according to practical reason which
he's gonna understand in terms of the
categorical imperative he doesn't think
that um
there's some further end for reason and
uh
it brings up some complicated issues
because on one hand you can see how far
he is from aristotle but then the
question i'd like to raise is just how
far is he from aristotle
um if aristotle's idea of
uh you know happiness or you know um is
um
you know
excellent activity excellent rational
activity right and so um you know kant
is going to say that
essentially that you know
human beings are sort of ordered to
um you know life according to reason you
know and uh
uh you know
it's a question that i think is is worth
thinking of
more than it is i mean oftentimes i
think uh
i i think kantians say well you know
uh you know obviously kant is very
different from aristotle because you
know kant rejects happiness you know and
then aristotelians often are like well
you know
continue
you know and so um
but um
just briefly though you know the
categorical categorical imperative
um is sort of uh if you look at the
argument it's what's left after he's
eliminated all these other sources of
moral worth um yeah he looks at
consequences of your actions you know um
to inclinations and what's interesting
these were all if you go and sort of
link these up these are all kind of
prominent moral theories some remain
some aren't not so much i mean one of
the ones that's kind of not around as
much maybe maybe you can find some uh
similarities today with uh some
emotivism or but you know this kind of
uh sentimentalism you know these kind of
uh people like uh
adam smith and you know um
but you know so criticizing these
popular theories
ultimately he doesn't think that um
for instance consequences purposes
inclinations
these things aren't adequate um
to be the source of
moral work as he says um so he follows
the categorical categorical imperative
and in this first or initial formulation
he says
i ought never to proceed except in such
a way that i could also will that my
maxim should become a universal law
um so this becomes the criteria for kant
and it's really interesting to think
about um because
there's a very strong difference with
aristotle so even though they sort of
agree in the role of reason
um centrality of reason to the moral
life um for kant
uh
this idea that um you know you should be
able to to universalize you know your
your action um without uh or your sort
of your intention without inconsistency
uh to make that a little more concrete
the example the most famous one is the
lying promise
you know so you know i promise okay well
you know um
i want to borrow some money you know i'm
hard up and i
i promise to borrow some money from you
you know and i promise to pay you back
uh
if you let me borrow money and i have no
intention of paying you back
god's idea not that
what happens
it happens i see that
idea is that uh you know essentially
it's a contradiction you know um
right because
uh on the one hand you know if i
universalize that that maxim as he calls
it which is the subjective principle of
my
my uh my willing or you know it's i mean
i we could sort of think of it as the
intention you know so i'm gonna tell
why well if i universalize that i'm
sorry i'm saying at the very least that
you know people can break their promises
you know and then on the other hand khan
is arguing that well the institution of
promising uh is presupposed so uh
another sense for me to be able to tell
a lying promise i have to presuppose
that no one should lie um
so you know
very sort of rationalist idea about what
um you know how you sort of uh evaluate
moral claims and so um
uh the problem is it doesn't work so
well once you get beyond the lying
province
uh it's a little bit more difficult for
him to
for instance argue that suicide is uh
is against the uh moral norm um so for
instance in suicide he has to bring in
uh this idea that
you know we have an inclination to
life all
living beings
have this sort of uh you know it's a
natural law of living beings that
they're ordered to preserve their life
so again you start to see well you know
um
it's it's not so clear
that the the two examples
uh you know um are are the same it seems
to be to get beyond um certain minimal
examples he's got to bring in um you
know
kind of uh
anthropological premises basically which
um
which he's ruled out really
yeah it seems to be should you know it
should you know it seems to be should be
ruled out you know it seems like the
virtue of kant is that he doesn't need
those sort of premises right that's what
it's presented as
but um
you know this is actually where one of
the points where and after virtue
mcintyre criticizes him i mean his
criticisms aren't probably the best that
we made but
um
i do think that
um more can be said about the
limitations of the categorical
imperative i think i think it's sort of
taken that well this is kind of an
adequate uh
norm because it works so well in line
promise case um not to say that
objections could be made to that either
but um you know when i teach this i i
first have to wean my students past the
notion that um we're just we're just
trying to say what if everybody did this
you know i wouldn't like that if
everybody did this we're supposed to
look for some sort of logical
contradiction
in
you know
the the the action itself and
what it would entail so the lying
promises is not that hard because you
can say well look you know nobody's
gonna believe anything because
the whole distinction between truth and
falsity would break down and and that
that they get and then we talk about
the suicide example and
you know then you're right it starts to
get a bit hazier and then when we start
getting to the imperfect duty examples
right
where it's no longer whether whether it
could be a universal law of nature
because kant says yeah just lay around
in the sun all day and don't do any work
or self-improvement that could actually
be how an entire society lives
you know he's actually wrong in his in
his um his pragmatic anthropology about
that saying that's how the south sea
islanders live anyway um
that's just bad you know anthropology
there but um but then it's harder to get
them to see well where is the inherent
contradiction in willing that and then
you know kant of course says
well you know
if nobody were to develop their talents
then i might need somebody else's you
know help at some point and
and
you know or if nobody's good to anybody
else you know i might need somebody's
help
and then you're like well that sounds
like consequentialism to me uh are you
smuggling that in and i think that you
could come up with some plausible
explanation where
somehow this is you know still flowing
out of pure reason
and it's it's all the concepts itself
but but i sure as hell don't know what
that is
myself
yeah
you know the point though
the point though i think that you know
that that could be made though you know
is that um
it really loses
like that pristine kind of even if you
could sort of draw it all out of pure
reason
um
you know um
again i mean it's gonna be a matter of
sort of uh much more uh complicated kind
of um
you know bringing in i mean well i i
should say rather you know i mean i i
don't think there's any sense in the you
get sort of just kind of a priori
develop this complete kind of so you
know it's gonna be a matter of him kind
of bringing in elements which are more
or less plausible but i mean i think
that um
you know the criticism con all often
makes of you know utilitarians or really
any anyone else you know is this idea
that well you know there's no certainty
because you know these are just based on
empirical matters you know and not based
on pure reason but as you point out once
you get past
you know very sim simple examples you
know there's no more certainty and cons
you know uh
and many i think contemporary kantians
reject his claims on suicide
you know
um
yeah you know a lot of times autonomy is
kind of used to
justify you know
one of the things that is interesting
about about kant's system as as a whole
is that
so happiness can't be the
the reason why i do what i'm supposed to
do it can't be my you know it can only
provide hypothetical imperatives to me
and those can't be you know truly moral
um and yet other people's happiness is
supposed to be of concern to me
and
other people's happiness is going to be
just as indeterminate and vague as my
own you know and yet at the same time
categorical imperative
when you know with some of his examples
says that i ought to be working for the
happiness of others so happiness gets
brought in
um
the happiness of others can be a
sufficient motive to me my happiness can
never be a sufficient motive for moral
action to me for him and so that i mean
there's a huge contrast there between
aristotle sometimes people you know
there's this big debate about aristotle
like 10 15 years ago as aristotle and
egoist and and there was a lot of ink
spilling i always thought well that's
just kind of dumb because you know
they're not reading enough aristotle to
realize that friendship really matters
and you're not you're not friends with a
friend just to get something out of them
that's the lower form of friendship
you know you're friends with them
because you actually you know you like
them and
they're part of your happiness and
you're part of their happiness and and
you know that's that's there with with
with kant
your happiness doesn't matter at all
except insofar as you you shouldn't make
yourself so miserable that you can't
fulfill your duties you know
so right
i mean uh
you know right for aristotle kant's life
would have been sort of below that right
he i mean like sort of a life alone you
know uh
well you know
without friend
count had friends and he was he was uh
kind of a bone vivant at these dinner
parties so apparently he had some social
interaction but then he had like this
you know very regimented
uh
life that he he also lived i don't know
i don't know that aristotle would have
been you know
into some guy that you could set your
clock by you know
should we should we take some questions
now um
we'll open it up so uh we've got a few
questions on the the q a app if you're
watching this we actually have the the
the app for questions enabled
um
we have two from christopher dunn and
both of these have to do more with with
the uh speculative philosophy than with
the practical philosophy but we can
still talk a bit about that
i will say this one of the the future
um
doctors say other forums that i have
lined up we're gonna have a a kant guy
who
you know he he can answer these sort of
questions in much greater depth and
detail a friend of mine morris morris
stern so let's let's start with uh
uh one that looks easy but isn't easy
here's a it reads here's a question from
kant's philosophy what is transcendental
idealism
um you want to handle that one
yeah i i suppose i could give it a shot
um so
i mean
roughly speaking um
kant uh
kant argues that um
you know he
sort of initiated this copernican
revolution
so that um you know um
the forms um you know the categories
that uh you know when we speak of you
know substance and accidents
uh relations you know um
but also you know things like natural
laws
causality
um
so we
ultimately
uh transcendental idealism was kant's
uh
uh argument that
uh the intelligibility of the world is
ultimately imposed
uh by the forms of sense sensibility uh
you know
the forms of uh
uh
understanding and uh sensibility that um
we basically bring to our experience so
uh it's sort of an attempt to solve uh
the problem of the debate between
the empiricists and the rationalists and
uh you know to kind of be a mediating
position so
uh
essentially his claim is that the
phenomenon that we experience
um
are not the things in themselves and
they're
they're
um both a product of you know
intuition or sensibility and which which
is sort of our encounter with these
things and also the forms that we impose
upon them and um
it's not exactly clear how you sort of
cut the joint there
and say what comes from what um but
anyway
uh that was that was my valiant attempt
well here's here's what i would would
add to it that's that's good because
that gives a good good basis explaining
that first part is always pretty tough
so you know with kant there's a really
strong distinction between the
theoretical or the speculative and then
the practical so
you know science um
epistemology
some parts of metaphysics over here in
the theoretical and then
um you know ethics and of course the
metaphysics underlying it the sort of
anthropology
that's in the practical
and when you do this copernican turn
and you say that um
what we're what we're able to know is is
a product of what we've imposed
on to this this whatever the experience
is
it means that there's when it comes to
like metaphysical issues
we can't know a hell of a lot over on
this side the speculative side that's
why if you compare the prolagomina to
any future metaphysics turns out you
really can't do any future metaphysics
of the important sort
except when it comes to the metaphysics
of morals
when it comes to
you know things like right
the good will duty
all of that
we can go beyond the realms of
experience and use
pure practical reason to sort of ferret
all these these things out so khan
thinks we can get a lot more mileage of
that
out of that but the problem is is the
the being that we're actually sort of
figuring all this stuff out of is is
just our numeral self it's not our
phenomenal self so you know like the
cells that are actually looking at each
other through these uh
these uh
webcams and and hearing each other talk
these are our phenomenal selves these
are selves that actually have a history
and identities you know names and stuff
like that and as a moral person that's
not i'm not really this
i'm something deeper
something that you know pure reason
itself can handle so it brings about
this kind of bifurcation of the the
person it seems like a lot of
um
a lot of the stuff that most of us in
our moral theory would say really really
matters to us ends up just being kind of
detritus that we have to to overlook
um
that's less a question about what kant's
transcendental idealism is and more an
answer about
what the effects of it are in in moral
theory i would say
um
so let's let's move on to another one
from from uh christopher dunn
um
there we go do you think i could have
gotten some of his ideas of
logic from roger bacon rather than
aristotle
what do you think
you know i am not an expert on
on khan's logic i mean other than you
know i mean
he was definitely heavily influenced by
aristotle i mean he he
um
you know depending on where you want to
but you if you want to talk about his
logic proper which i mean he sort of
wrote after the critiques but i mean
um you know i mean um
he he thought that he was sort of
completing what aristotle was doing with
the categories let's say you know so um
but i mean i'm sure that uh you know
i i wouldn't be surprised if they can
you know have to memorize but i really
don't know much about that
yeah i i don't really either i i know a
little more about his logic than what
you've you've said other than you know
he's he's working off of what people at
the time are
are uh are using and a lot of that was
aristotelian um
it really depends on
on uh
you know there's logic in the sense of
like logic the the course that you teach
because because can't taught that stuff
and then there's like the underlying
logic of of what it is that you're
you're up to
um
and there i mean kant really is a
rationalist he he really thinks that you
can
you can figure out the basic
structures of
how everything is put together
because that's what the categories are
and that's what you know
ideals of reason going beyond you know
the categories going back beyond
experience that's what those are we can
we can putter around with those and make
sense of those
um
using using reason
otherwise i don't have quite so much to
say about that myself that would be a
great question for for morris when he
comes on because he is like you know
straight out guy
who uh
understands the theoretical stuff just
just as well as the practical stuff
i'd be interested in the question yeah i
know
yeah any other uh questions or comments
that that people have go ahead and use
the the q a app
and we'll
we'll uh
field them
let me see if there's anything on the uh
the uh
page itself
um
oh here here's one
um
this was asked by the fates of warned
in what ways do you think aristotle's
works and ethics may influence kant
and what are some ways in which aspects
of kant's ethics may be analogous to
aristotle's so we talked a lot about the
differences
what are some of the similarities we
could say between these guys
um
yeah i mean on the one hand i really
don't think that i think it's
um pretty much the kind of scholarly
consensus that
uh kant really didn't know very much
about aristotle it wasn't
um
you know aristotle's ethics he wasn't
sort of uh
uh
you know very well versed and you don't
see the kind of i mean where he does
engage with like epic epicureans you
know stoics and you know so um but um as
i mentioned before
um i think the similarity
uh is in the sense that i i think both
of them are rationalists of stores there
are different types of rationales but
you know aristotle the ethical life is
life according to reason you know and
that um
uh
kant you know
for contest the same you know in a sense
it's the same same view you know now
although they understand that very
differently but um
so i think that for both um
for both they think that um
you know
common uh
you know average person um does not
give reason a central place
in their life does not give enough
place to reason in their life you know
and aristotle supposedly saying this and
cons you know constantly kind of uh
pointing to
your inclinations and kind of you know
the impurity of you know morals
um so um
you know i think that um there are
similarities in terms of reason and the
difference is it is in terms of how they
understand reason
uh you know that comes from the
what 2000 year difference or so 2200
year difference uh
yeah
you know i mean historically you're
right there weren't a lot of people at
that time
who were paying close attention to
aristotle's texts he'd been kind of
thrown away along with you know
moribund scholasticism
which you know is really
the fault of a lot of the people who
taught aristotle very very terribly for
years and years
you know
um
but you know the if you look at the
classical authors who the 18th century
was interested in you're right it was
epicurus
epictetus those were huge guys there was
a you know some recovery of plato
and the other person who was read you
know
who does hume quote the most uh cicero
and what's interesting with cicero
cicero's you know espousing a certain
kind of stoicism mixed in with a certain
kind of aristotelianism mixed in with
some skepticism it's really hard to
figure out where he he lies but he sets
up these debates
and
in these debates the the big heavy
hitters are usually the hellenistic
schools it's the stoics the skeptics and
the epicureans
arguing with each other and there'll be
an odd aristotelian coming in but they
never really have much to say
so so it's understandable that that you
know when kant is thinking about
eudaimianism
he's not targeting an aristotle that he
truly knew just like when kant is
criticizing the ontological argument in
the first critique kant didn't really
you know he knew descartes well he
didn't know anselm very well
um
so he's you know he he's
he's somewhat of a creature of his
intellectual milieu in that sense
if you were to bring like imagine we had
a bar where we could like
bring philosophers in from any any time
any century and sit down and have drinks
with them if they had drinks i don't
know you know
how how willing they'd be some of them
to do that and we could sit comp down
and say look you know here's what this
guy is actually saying why don't you
listen to them for a while you know let
them talk
back and forth modern-day classroom he'd
have to revise quite a few of his views
on the inferiority of women or thing you
know
stuff like that pretty quick
especially if he saw some you know
female student interpreting his text and
saying hey what about this
so yeah that's that's probably uh
there's also one other point you know
towards the end of the uh
the
groundwork um and i think maybe he
addressed it in the in the
critique of practical reason as well but
the idea of like a perfectionism
um you know some sort of rationalist
views of that kind of approach
um in some sense an aristotelian or to
mystic view of uh
you know uh i mean
in a sense right aquinas kind of
interprets
aristotle in these terms that it's sort
of um
this sort of uh you know uh fulfillment
of kind of nature you know it's this
kind of perfectionism that it's it's
somewhat similar and kant uh
it doesn't really give much um
much time to deal with it i mean
essentially his claim is that
you know
well he can't really give any content to
that you know
um it's the same kind of claim made
about happiness right that you know it
doesn't lack this kind of determinate
context
and i i think that that's just really uh
just an unfair criticism because i think
that the same claim could be pointed to
his
you know categorical imperative that
when you start to get down to it you
know
you have to kind of things get rough
around the edges once you start to try
to get deal with concrete issues and
um yeah again maybe with a plug to
aristotle right aristotle knew this he
said you you should be you should be
intelligent enough to recognize the kind
of certainty that you can get according
to the matter
yeah yeah that's an important point so
we have two other questions um
this is going to be one that's not
really so much about counter aristotle
it's by justin gulley
and there it is who might be considered
a great philosopher here in our time and
what philosophical movement is
dominating discourse today that's a
that's a
that's a good question you want to take
the first one i'll take the second one
sure sure um
so um
you know great philosopher well i mean i
i of course would like to say you know i
think alexander mcintyre
is uh someone who um you know
kind of uh will will
stand the test of time i think that he's
uh
you know probably one of the best uh you
know living philosophers without a doubt
and um
uh i mean others you might throw in i
mean
depending on what you mean by our time i
i would i would include
you know somebody like quan i think is
you know the brilliant um blocker i mean
he's
not quite at our time but pretty close
um
um
wickenstein um
but you know at least contemporaries you
know um
yeah i mean i would i would point you
out
yeah if you look at i mean who else are
really big figures right now you have um
peter singer so he's a representative of
utilitarianism
um
who would be
you know
you could point to robert brandon who's
doing some interesting things with hegel
and language
there you know in continental philosophy
we can we can easily point to people
like like slavoji jacques um
yeah
and uh bad you is a guy who's really
interested in classical philosophy and
bringing it up to the the present day
but you know i think that you
one of the things you said really put
your put put your finger right on what's
most important
um it's not just who's considered a
great philosopher here in our time
because if you look at any given epoch
there's always people who are like you
know the guy you know think about like
herbert spencer but in his day he was
the guy and nobody reads him anymore
because his stuff is just you know
really
dull stuff there's nothing there's not a
lot of great you know thoughts there
macintyre i think you're right is going
to be somebody people are going to be
reading 100 years from now i don't know
that people are going to be reading a
singer 100 years from now except for a
specialist you know
um what philosophical movement is
dominating discourse today
i don't think there is one
that's part of the problem
uh in in america and and in britain in
the commonwealth countries
analytic philosophy
is really big
but
some analytics will speak of a
post-analytic phase and i think that
we're really at the point
where the people who are doing analytic
philosophy
uh
a lot of them can't talk to each other
they may have some sort of original
common roots and and think that they
have a common methodology
but they've all coined their own
scholastic vocabulary
and they don't map on to each other that
well so you know what does externalism
mean in this context versus this context
or this context they love isms you know
they love to coin new terms
and oftentimes they they don't have a
good grounding in the in the the history
of philosophy and they don't know enough
about what it would be to have a
grounding in the history of philosophy
to recognize that they don't have a good
grounding in it which is the source
that's the roots you know
and then we've got continental
philosophy and continental philosophies
all over the map you know it like blends
into cultural studies and some of it's
just weird wacky stuff that you know
you know
nobody's going to read 20 years from now
um yeah nobody can read now
well there's some good stuff out there
that's being done in it but you know
you got to wade through so much
yeah
and continental philosophy doesn't map
on to european philosophy so there's all
these great catholic thinkers that
should be part of the continental canon
like dietrich von hildenbrandt or
maurice blondell or gabriel marcel and
they're not
because uh they're not you know
they're not hiding or loving us or their
dairy die they're not sexy enough
and then you know there's you could say
there's the catholic intellectual
tradition um which is not just
identifiable with tomism but but thomas
plays a major role in that
um and then there's you know classical
american philosophy which is kind of a
niche thing these days but but
deserves some some more study and and uh
then there's people like like me who
just
you know
i read aristotle to read aristotle
or you know when i read thomas people
there was there was a facebook thing the
other day people were like who do you
like for reading thomas you know what's
what's the best you know author on
thomas and i said well it's kind of good
to read thomas himself see what he
actually said you know uh when i'm inter
when i'm reading thomas i'm mostly
interested in figuring out you know what
he's doing because i i take seriously
what he's up to
um so that i mean i
i sort of like laid out a map with a
bunch of different countries in
it none of them are really dominant
and
if you depending on where you're going
to school or what journals you're
reading or
you know who the local
university is into it's like a total
patchwork
i mean you could like
you could be in a university town and go
down the street and there'll be people
that are doing continental and then over
here they do analytic and
the other thing too is a lot of
philosophy isn't being done in
philosophy departments anymore it's done
in history departments poli-sci
departments
um
english departments
sociology
you know the place where i teach uh
right right now
um we have a required ethics course and
then i'll walk down the halls and i'll
hear these business business you know
classes doing doing ethics
and there's like total disconnect
between
our department and their department
um
so it's very difficult to say who's
dominating i'd say it's one of those
sort of things where nobody knows who's
in charge
yeah
yeah i mean i think that uh
there's a lot of
possibilities currently you know that
you know analytical philosophy seems to
sort of lost its self-certainty you know
and uh continental philosophy has been
that way for for quite a while and uh
yeah you know so
uh you know it'd be interesting to see
whether you know um
how things will kind of evolve
yeah i think that the core is always
going to be the historical figures
the ones who actually have stood the
test of time people are always going to
be reading kant and they're always going
to be reading aristotle
and you know i think you're right 100
years from now they're going to be
reading mcintyre so
let's let's uh
do another one real quick and then we'll
do like some some ross and mcintyre
discussion
this one is also by christopher dunn and
we've talked about some of this already
since we're talking about happiness what
would aristotle call happiness also how
would aristotle measure happiness the
second part is probably more interesting
because we know what aristotle says
happiness is it's you know a virtuous
activity
you have to have a certain amount of
property or wealth you know so that
you're not destitute and it should be
shared with family and friends
how do you measure it that's a good
question
yeah i think that um you know when you
when you come to
you think about measuring happiness or
you know
um
you know this is the point where
um
you can't let the measure determine you
know
what's being measured and i think that
this is the kind of tendency right with
you know uh especially like again in
modern economics and you know i mean in
these kind of contexts
um
you know for aristotle um right so so in
the contemporary you know you might have
something like gdp is being thought of
as like a measure of happiness you know
or well-being or you might have these um
positive psychology the empirical
psychology
uh
you know
empirical psychologists who are sort of
uh doing surveys to kind of measure
subjective well-being um
you know and so you know for aristotle
um
there's no sort of uh
there's no sort of joint where you can
get at kind of foundationally and say
okay well you know if you have you know
this much wealth or you know you know we
get this score on you know for instance
subjective well-being kind of uh surveys
you know
so for aristotle um you know happiness
and the question of whether someone's
happy
is not independent of the regime
and you know the the um
the character of the kind of people
participating so i mean ultimately like
the measure of happiness in aristotle is
the virtuous man you know like there's
no
uh
there's no sort of independent way of
measuring i mean i guess that's sort of
what i'm trying to get at is that um
you know ultimately
being happy is
what the virtuous person kind of
understands is happiness
yeah i think you know
it could be possible to say
um things in terms of more and less
happiness
um
but i i think that there isn't going to
be any sort of objective measure that we
can use across the board and it's going
to be
subjective
not just in the sense that you know
different people are going to look at it
different ways but more in this this
sense of subjectivity that is the
individual person
will be able to say to themselves once
they've progressed to a certain stage
this isn't it yet i need something more
than this
and i thought that this was was going to
be
happiness but but um this isn't quite it
and and what would i need i i need my
life to be a bit more rational i would
need myself to be a bit more virtuous i
would need my you know the fabric of my
relationships to be
to be better
um
you know when we think about this term
virtuous activity and what that consists
in
uh if we're talking about the moral
virtues
aristotle calls that the political life
but we should probably understand that
in terms of the social life right if we
use the latin
you know social rather than the greek
polis and and and that can be lived out
in in uh
you know in terms of a political
community although that's the kind of
political communities we live in now
that's pretty tough except at a local
level
or it can be lived out through um
here's where i think people like like
john stuart mill and alexis de
tocqueville
these are
useful first you know sort of filling
out the picture
what what de tocqueville called
intermediate associations clubs
organizations
uh your workplace all these sorts of
things circles of friends and and family
um
school groups you know your your class
um all of those could be places in which
we
we actually get to live out the life of
a virtue which which involves you know
developing more and more virtue and and
making it actual
um
i'm willing to bet too if aristotle were
to sit down and like you know say i need
to write a few more chapters he'd
probably talk a bit about
how
the cultivation of our own virtue should
lead to
it should spill over into helping other
people cultivate their virtue like
mentoring relations you know
um that would be an example of that sort
of thing so now
you know how do you measure that sort of
thing you're right those those
you go to like the authentic happiness
project and you look at their surveys
i did some of them and i'm like man i
could i could have wide my butt off on
these
and i i have no self knowledge
whatsoever
there's no controls for that sort of
thing
um
what you would need and this is you know
this is why it gets kind of tough for
for
bringing this across to
non-aristotelians
what you would need is somebody who
actually
is if not you know completely virtuous
at least like on the way there
to be the judge
and you'd have to subject you or your
you know you'd have to say here what do
you think
you know i don't know if i'm actually
that happy right now and i'm not sure
why then you go to somebody like that
and you know we have that
but it's always contingent we have that
you know through
things like spiritual direction if
you've got a good spiritual director we
have that through psychotherapy
sometimes
we have that through coaching
we have that through
people who are really squared away in
our own lives who are fortunate enough
to run across um and you know generous
enough to actually like you know give us
their advice and their time and put up
with our bs until we get our act
together
um
but that's always contingent it's not
like you could have a
a
um
leadership training program that would
give you all the criteria for figuring
out what a virtuous person is because
for an asus is part of it you know
that's kind of a long answer
well should we uh
probably
go ahead
yeah i think so now as you say it's long
and probably unfortunately unsatisfying
but that's sort of the best
sort of the best you can get without um
sort of getting inside aristotle's
you know
to see why that makes sense you sort of
have to understand uh
you know sort of why aristotle's claims
are more plausible say than other
yeah
should we talk now about ross and and
then a bit more about alistair matt
put in a plug for the guy that we
particularly like
so so i'll talk about ross um he's a guy
i actually find really fascinating
because
he writes his dissertation on kant and
he's really well known for work on
aristotle so he's somebody who kind of
fits in here well and we teach him
sometimes in moral theory classes as a
deontologist
because we focus on the part of his book
that has to do with duty
um
but he also has a lot of aristotelian
conceptions and he's trying to you know
like fuse these two guys together i'm
not sure that he's really that
successful
and i think he's really more different
from kant than he is similar to kant so
he's if he's in the deontological camp
he's in the far aristotelian wing of it
you know
so
here's here's some ways that that that
ross is different than kant he
kant wants to say all of our duties
can be reduced to one basic principle or
ground the categorical imperative and
ross says nah you can't do that it's
we've actually got a lot of different
grounds for why we we have the
particular duties that we have
he also rejects kant's notion of perfect
duties that never admit of any
exceptions so he's willing to say
there's sometimes we probably ought to
lie you know to prevent greater harm
occurring but most of the time we ought
to follow these what he calls prima
facie duties and he he comes up with
seven and he says
i don't say that this is exhaustive i i
think that there's you know possibly
other ones
and and other people have uh
have done that as well you know they've
um
they've added to his his notions
so
he
he he's you know he's committed to this
notion of of a
whole plethora of
prima fascia like on their face duties
you know things like
gratitude and reparation i hurt somebody
i should i should do something to make
up for it and he's not even concerned
with
how do you feel
he's not you know he says it doesn't
matter whether you feel bad about it you
do something you know so there is the
duty orientation
um he is similar to count and that he's
rejecting any kind of
egoist or utilitarian consequentialism
and he thinks he does think that that
when it comes to what we ought to do the
right that is divorced from
our own happiness or flourishing or
fulfillment
and he agrees what he does like about
county says
kant says that you ought to seek to make
yourself good and make other people
happy so you know that that same
emphasis of uh
you happiness doesn't matter to you but
it does you know to these others and you
ought to take care of them
where he gets really aristotelian
is in saying how do you figure out you
know what your duties are
so he says um
these are self-evident but they're not
self-evident like everybody's going to
automatically get them he says the
nature of the self-evident is not to be
evident to every mind however
undeveloped
but to be apprehended directly by minds
which have reached a certain stage of
maturity and for minds to reach the
necessary stage of maturity the
development that takes place from
generation to generation
is needed
uh is as much needed as that which takes
place from infancy to adult life so he's
got these two sort of overlapping
dimensions there's
you know if you're if you're in a
household that's not you know totally
screwed up you ought to as you go from
being a little kid to being an adult
mature and you ought to start seeing
that you shouldn't you know shouldn't
beat people up or steal or you know
pick whatever you want when you hurt
somebody you ought to help them up
but he also thinks that this has been
happening over the
the course of time over generations so
there's a kind of
progressive
element to it and he says um
i would maintain that what we are apt to
describe is what we think about moral
questions contains a considerable amount
we don't think but no and this forms the
standard by reference to which the truth
of any moral theory has to be tested so
he's saying
moral theories they're great
but you don't want to subject morality
to them you measure
whether the moral theory is any good by
seeing whether it lines up with with our
basic conceptions about how how we ought
to behave
so he says
we have no more direct way of access to
the facts about rightness and goodness
and about what things are right or good
than by thinking about them
the moral convictions of the thoughtful
and well-educated people are the data of
ethics just as sense perceptions are the
data of natural science
just as some of the latter have to be
rejected as illusory so have some of the
former
but
as the latter are rejected only when
they're in conflict with some other more
accurate sense perceptions the former
rejected only when they're in conflict
with other convictions which better
stand the test of reflection
and he says the existing body of moral
convictions of the best people so
there's the aristotelian thing
is the cumulative product of the moral
reflection of many generations which has
developed an extremely delicate power of
appreciation of moral distinctions
and this the theorist cannot afford to
treat with anything other than the
greatest respect the verdicts of the
moral consciousness of the best people
are the foundation on which he must
build now i think ross is is is a little
bit optimistic for our own times
um and perhaps even for his own time
maybe he should have gotten out outside
of you know a university town a bit more
um
but this notion that that the uh it's
you have to have a certain amount of
development before you're admitted to
the conversation
eminently aristotelian you know
um and i think that's something that
aristotle gets that kant doesn't get
for kant it is sort of like a matter of
logic look you can lay this stuff out
and anybody should be able to to see
through it you know
once they get past the terminology
aristotle says no in order for you to
reason well you you have to at least
have some sort of moral basis that's
that's developed otherwise you're not
going to be able to do it you can maybe
do mathematics okay
and you can do theoretical things okay
and play the flute just fine you know
techne
but
figuring out what's actually good for
human beings and how you want to run
your life
that requires that you already have
something to bring to the table that
you've already worked a bit you know
so yeah i think that's a um
i think
it's a really good insight you know that
i think that is for some reason easily
forgotten you know we we i don't know if
it's our
you mentioned chuckle earlier you know
our democratic age that we just kind of
um
that doesn't sit well with us but we we
sort of feel like you know everybody
ought you know everybody's opinions
you know are equal or at least ought to
equally be heard whereas you know
aristotle
he's fine with saying basically well
look for a lot of people i mean
essentially and not so many words says
that you know
we don't really need to ask a lot of
people what they think
uh you know happiness is because they
have no idea they're just interested in
you know seeking pleasure you know so i
mean it's uh
you know
uh well i mean
that that seems to be i mean like you
mentioned i mean
how does a guy like ross
uh deal with
the fact of you know uh
plurality you know radical plurality
which we seem to be much more aware of
nowadays
yeah i don't i don't see him actually
doing that unfortunately um at least not
in the right and the good uh and that's
the only work by ross in moral theory
that's not a commentary in aristotle
that i've read
so
he may have an answer to that that
somewhere but
um i don't know a lot of these these
early 20th century british guys they
were the they were sort of like brought
up in in the circumstances that
aristotle would say
conduces to moral um development you
know the the right household not like
the most of us you know we grew up in
all sorts of screwed up households and
according to aristotle we probably
couldn't make much development at all
you know
given the basis that we had which which
is one reason why aristotle has to be
revised when it comes to those sort of
things
but i i don't see ross really thinking
that through very much i think he'd give
some people a blank stare and say well
look
you don't think that it's your duty to
tell the truth oh
that that's interesting
you know i certainly won't trust you
with anything then yeah
yeah yeah i think that's as far as you
can get
um so mcintyre this is a good transition
point to mcintyre because mcintyre's
writing
in
a situation where things have all broken
down you know
yeah um
i mean that's i think
one of his kind of
you know greatest virtues let's say is
kind of
really wanting to face this fact of kind
of moral disagreement you know and i
mean that's how after virtue begins
right you know and he's sort of looking
at
um
he likens our situation to
uh
the
situation uh if
if if anyone's familiar with the
chemical for labor with you know oh yeah
yeah
sort of example that he draws you know
where um the thought experiment from
that book basically uh tweaks it some
but the idea is being that well you know
if
you know all of uh let's say there was a
some sort of disaster caused by science
and people got angry they destroyed
laboratories
you know burn books and things and then
you know uh
just basically outlawed science and then
you know
100 200 years down the road people start
discovering manuscripts that are you
know only half uh legible you know and
recovering bits and pieces
um
you know and they start to put them
together and come up with a coherent
more uh
scientific theories you know and they
have sort of newton you know
and einstein intertwined in ways that uh
contemporary physicists you know would
see a clear misunderstanding of the
relationship between the two you know
and so
um this is the the analogy he wants to
draw to our moral situation that
basically
um the moral
concepts and and basically our moral
terminology
uh has been uprooted from its social
context and that we are in a situation
where
you know um at least you know your
average person is kind of willing to
kind of
uh you know one minute kind of appeal to
you know principle the greatest
happiness the next minute you know he's
kind of drawing in
aristotelian conceptions of justice
um you know followed by you know
kind of uh an appeal to universality you
know and then you know
um and
the situation he calls it ultimately is
emotivism where
um you know ultimately
you know um
what purports to be in what looks like
an appeal to an objective moral
principle oh this is this is for the
greatest happiness or you know this is
what's just
is ultimately
uh driven by you know um or expression
of
you know someone's emotions basically
they want some given circumstance a
given goal so they can appeal to a
you know a moral norm to justify you
know that course of action
interestingly i saw in a book on applied
ethics uh
uh where this was basically
these were the instructions figure out
what you want and then and then adopt
the moral principle that will
enable you to
score
wow
yeah it ends up effectively reducing uh
moral language and moral reasoning just
to a rhetoric you know how to get people
to and this is what the emotivist said
they said it's not just that it's an
expression of your own you know desires
preferences it's also an attempt to get
everybody else to see things
and not really see things feel things
your way
and and you know
either like seduce them into that or
scare them into that or bring social
pressure to bear on them you know and if
that's all that we've got to work with
we're screwed you know then then
yeah i know it's inherently manipulative
as you point out you know it's and
that's the big point that mcintyre is
wanting to kind of play up is that you
know like you said if that's all we have
then we're essentially in a situation
where our social life consists of
manipulating those people around us yeah
see things or feel things in our way
which doesn't seem to be a very
appealing situation you know and um
uh so mcintyre um you know again just
briefly like you know
he he thinks this came about
because um ultimately the rejection of
aristotelian
teleology he thinks for you know a
variety of reasons uh you know the
reformation the scientific
uh
revolution um you know and uh the
industrial revolution there's a variety
of factors he puts in the background
kind of
making aristotle seem kind of
implausible and uh you know i mean
people have kind of tried to
chart this and um
but i mean it's as
you mentioned earlier right it was
pretty clear that there was wasn't much
interest in aristotle at this time you
know and um
so um you know early modern period let's
say you know um and so
um
so basically what he's saying that you
know you have
the idea of uh you know
you are now
um
where you could be you know if you reach
or tell us
and the goal i mean the virtues and
norms that will sort of enable you
to get from point a to point b well in
mcintyre's view what essentially
happened was
point b dropped off so the idea of who
you could become or the to tell us was
sort of lost and so you had
a variety of moral theorists who were
basically trying to
like the example from earlier the
chemicals from liverwood put the pieces
together without all the pieces so
you know they're trying to find a role
for a moral norm or or you know some
sort of virtue or something
without you know it's it's reason for
being the the goal that
it would enable you to reach so you know
he looks at somebody like kant
especially
it's kind of a prime example of this you
know but um he also points it you know
um
uh
you know these kind of uh sentimental
hume um
uh some of these others who are kind of
looking to put moral uh
the source of moral norms and
inclination
um but what's interesting is like you
know it's really his reading of his
history and trying to uh
kind of
you know kind of give it a kind of a
genealogy of how we got to this
situation where you know we don't seem
to really know what morality is and how
we sort of uh
you know um and so um
he thinks that um really
uh kierkegaard
kind of understood this in a sense and
kind of um but but not not quite as
clearly as nietzsche that basically
um without the telos
um
you don't have
uh any any morality right and it can
essentially be a creation you know our
nature senses you become kind of a
self-creation you know and um so um you
know you think that this sort of
radical willfulness that you find in
nietzsche about you know um
creating news or you know things like
that right it's
is intelligible in terms of this history
and um
so you know mcintyre thinks that i mean
he's got a famous chapter in the middle
of after virtue you know uh nietzsche or
aristotle yeah basically
you know sensible you know nietzsche's
you know
you know in a few apparitions he he took
he did what you know it took years for
these kind of oxford you know analytical
philosophers to do basically demolish
all modern moral philosophy and that um
you know but nietzsche really didn't
engage with aristotle and that um
you know that he thinks that that
aristotelianism isn't
uh you know uh susceptible to the same
criticisms that nietzsche is offering of
you know uh
or you know just in general there's no
sort of grounding for these moral norms
so um
you know and and he he offers a few
reasons you know for kind of preferring
the aristotle nietzsche but i mean uh
you know a couple you know most
prominent i mean um
the idea that you know nietzsche's
history
is essentially sort of
you know falsified that you know he has
a picture of the aristocracy uh you know
the aristotelian aristocracy uh as this
sort of uh you know
domineering and dominating kind of uh
you know um
you know kind of power hungry um and you
know mcintyre's claim is that you know
it's really kind of a misunderstanding
of
uh
you know the role or or or the actual
history and so he tries to do some
things and look at the way that um
you know uh
virtues kind of function in this kind of
context
um
and and the other the other kind of
criticism that he offered um you know
just the idea that
you know uh nietzsche's
solutions were just you know i think he
calls it a it should be relegated to the
philosophical bestiary i think he says
you know the ubermensch you know that
you know this is not something that
we're we we need or that we're you know
um i mean there's all these claims right
about the the influence of nietzsche on
not nazism you know whether there's you
know but i mean regardless the idea of
sort of uh creating new
sort of values you know
seems inherently problematic you know
and so um mcintyre's idea again kind of
it's rooted in this kind of going back
to the history
it's to look at the um
the forms of life and the practices
where
moral norms become intelligent and so
that's where
um
let's let's take our last uh
question which isn't actually a question
uh it's coming from don key
so
are we screwed that's that's the person
to stop with
perfect segue into the
conclusion of mcintyre is that you know
ultimately mcintyre thinks that um
you know there are some sort of pockets
of uh
you know on the periphery where
um the virtues are still practiced
conceptions of the common good just all
those key notions from aristotle are
still are still actually operative
they're still they find applications and
so um you know
he hasn't given a lot of examples but
you know um
it kind of goes with his own position
that you know and as you can see with
aristotle's right that there's no
there's no criteria for happiness right
so it wouldn't wouldn't really be
plausible for mcintyre to come off and
say okay well and the xyz community you
know this you know he's pointed to
communities uh one example of like
fishing communities
um you know um but he's talked to abroad
you know in different contexts of a
variety of different uh you know local
communities basically where
again conceptions of the common good
uh you know or kind of
common notions of kind of
happiness are still embodied and the
virtues are still practiced and there's
still
um a notion of kind of a
politics and in a sense and ethics as
well that are kind of rooted in that
kind of concrete uh
you know uh context you know so
um
yeah it's not entirely different
it's an optimistic pessimism i guess
there are pessimistic optimism you know
yeah uh yeah that's that's a good way to
put it it's sort of like um
his viewpoint is not going to be
compatible with with every you know
modern way of living if you want to not
be screwed then you have to make certain
choices and some of those choices are
what you're going to align yourself with
and what you're going to involve
yourself with and it's not he's not
laying out something in a utopian
fashion or in on sort of
cover everybody universal fashion
and it's not the sort of you know
conception of liberalism uh you know
where everybody gets to just sort of
pick and choose and anything's just as
good as anything else so long as
somebody gets into it there are
consequences that come from choosing
certain lifestyles or choosing certain
ways of life and some of us are you know
more screwed at the start than others
some of us get a leg up and some of us
don't
and even but the good thing is in a
modern society
even if we don't get a leg up
there's resources that are
fairly readily a bit available
that you can you can latch on to and
those resources tend to look like you
know the central conceptions of
aristotelian moral theory and mcintyre
is willing to say
that
you don't you know you're not going to
actually like improve people's lives by
giving them nico mccain ethics book one
and and somatiologica
you know
uh primus
you know questions uh one and two to
noah on you're gonna have discourses
with them that kind of go along with
those those insights you're gonna lead
them dialectically through that and say
well so so this this is what you think
the good life is like is that is that
really satisfying you and what what do
you think
what do you think would be better
and that's you know so there is hope
there is there is something uh uh better
so why don't we um
use that as our sort of
end point to cap this off um i'd like to
thank caleb for
for being willing to come on here and
share his expertise in all these
different subject areas with us and
there's his reflections
it's great i appreciate it i had a lot
of fun and uh yeah i really appreciate
you having me on
yeah this is this is a lot of a lot of
fun
so uh to everybody out there um
have a good night and uh
try to be an aristotelian
i'll let you have the last word
um
i i i suppose um
uh
in lieu of reading uh book of the uh
of the naked mccain ethics uh
find somewhere where you can go practice
the virtue
that's good
find a good mentor